la parole est à madame claude greff
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre qui n'est plus là
j'associe à ma question mon collègue le
questeur fait les brillants qui comme
moi appris par voie de presse
votre décision en effet vous avez décidé
que le cea le centre de coma ce
commissariat à l'énergie atomique du riz
peau en indre et loire seraient fermés
pour rejoindre la région aquitaine
près de 600 salariés sont concernés par
cette fermeture ainsi que plus d'un
millier de personnels d'entreprises sous
traitantes
ce mardi 9 juin les salariés du ca du
ripaud manifestent devant le ministère
de la défense
ils veulent savoir pourquoi cette
fermeture ils comprennent bien qu'il est
nécessaire d'anticiper les contraintes
budgétaires pour 2020 2025
mais alors pourquoi le 11 octobre
dernier avant les élections
départementales
madame touraine dans sa circonscription
d'élection mais aussi ancienne
présidente du conseil général d'indre et
loire annonce au sujet de cette
fermeture dans la presse locale je cite
je veux que tout le monde soit rassuré
le riz peau ne fermera pas et conservera
ses salariés encore une promesse non
tenue du gouvernement pourquoi ce qui
était vrai avant les élections ne l'est
plus comme par hasard après que vous
ayez perdu les élections départementales
voulez vous encore à couvrir cette
région centre val de loire autrefois
présidé par monsieur michel sapin qui
est très impactés par de nombreux plans
sociaux et notamment michelin en 2014
étiez aux commandes en 2014 avec notre
de redécoupage c'est bien vous qui en
fait la plus faible régions de france
cette région val de loire vous favoriser
davantage évidemment la région aquitaine
présidée par monsieur rue c'est pourquoi
votre audition est injuste c'est un choc
pour les salariés les familles et les
salariés regrettent le manque de
scénarii alternative étudier ensemble
avec les personnels et les représentants
monsieur le premier ministre sous
couvert du secret défense vous ne donnez
aucune explication crédible sur cette
fermeture vous sacrifier l'emploi
tourangeau vous devez revenir sur votre
décision étudie avec tous les honneurs
madame gueule la parole est à monsieur
jean marie le guen secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le président
mesdames et messieurs les beats et vous
plaît s'il vous plaît
graff il vous plait le gouvernement est
très attentif évidemment à la situation
des salariés du riz peau et d'ailleurs
ils seront reçus cet après midi par le
ministre de la défense que je veux
excuser
puisque il est en déplacement en tunisie
ne peux donc vous répondre immédiatement
vous le savez même si vous l'avez pas
souligné madame la députée aujourd'hui
cette structure du cea est dans une
période de bas de cycle parce que nous
sommes à la fin de la production d'un
certain nombre de dispositifs militaires
que ces dispositifs militaires
reprendront d'ici quelques années mais
nous sommes dans un creux de
prévue par la loi de programmation
militaire et qui est débattu encore
aujourd'hui par notre assemblée
évidemment vous l'avez vous même
souligné personne ici est certainement
pas vous parce que je sais que vous êtes
très attaché à la problématique de la
dépense publique
je vous ai entendu à de nombreuses
reprises sur ce sujet personne ne peut
imaginer que il n'y ait pas une volonté
de rationaliser la dépense publique y
compris au sein du budget de la défense
alors parce que nous connaissons
l'attachement des salariés au centre du
riz peau et notamment des tourangeaux
bien d'une façon plus générale ce qui
contribue à la vie locale ce qui est
aujourd'hui vous avez peut-être oublié
de le souligner madame ce n'est pas la
suppression d'emplois mais une
réorganisation territoriale de
l'activité nucléaire du cea
d'une façon plus précis je tiens à vous
dire que l'activité liée aux pôles
lavoisier a vocation à rester oripeaux
voilà madame la députée ce que nous
voulions vous dire pour vous rassurer